I read the script in 2007 and you know
that was only two months after having
moved to this country in order to try
and pursue a Hollywood career and this
thing just blew my head off the idea of
playing dr. King it was a look I
wouldn't cost me as as him for obvious
reasons the accent is very strange and
but like I say I sort of had this
spiritual connection to it and then it
wasn't till actually three years on that
a director came along in the shape of
Lee Daniels who wanted me for the role
the initial director didn't and and we
just couldn't get the film off the
ground for various reasons Lee and I
went on to do the butler instead he felt
having touched on civil rights as a
subject matter he wanted to move on and
in the meantime I had done a beautiful
film with Ava called middle of nowhere
and just fell head-over-heels in love
with her talent and became an advocate
for her to be the one to direct this
movie and thankfully the producers
agreed and she came on board there was a
seven-year journey and how he and the
band of brothers and sisters around him
who you know bolstered him so that he
could do that so it was really important
to you know give the texture and and in
the tone the the toxicity the triumph
the tragedy of that place that is Selma
my father is from Lowndes County Alabama
which is something that David didn't
know about as he was advocating for me
so I really know that place many summer
vacations Christmases new years Father's
Day Mother's Day I'll be there for
Christmas this year after our film opens
in LA in New York I fly to Montgomery
and so I know that place and so it was
really about imbuing the script with a
sense of a place and of time that's why
we open it with the four little girls
just feel it's important to not sanitize
that time in history and say it was a
violent but really feel the violence
looking at that other people in history
like Haley Haley Cooper and and and all
the other characters who were part of
the movement it wasn't just dr. King as
it was all his team
it's easy to to just focus on King but
King like I said was a leader of men and
women and the stories are so vibrant
they're so robust so rich of the
characters and the people who really
made it so that people like me that we
could all be sitting here with you you
know that that that was was not the case
50 years ago that we could all be here
together in a room and so how that came
to be was the work of a lot of people of
all colors of all creeds James Reid
Viola Louise Oh Roy read the New York
Times reporter everyone is real that's
named in the film everyone is real and
and everyone played a part
Carmen you have played Coretta Scott
King before in a film called boycott
boycott I I'm playing Coretta Scott King
in 1955 and it's really at a point in
which she's at a very different place in
her marriage the kings as a couple have
just been recently thrust into the the
position of leadership and were still
really finding their way and there was a
buoyancy I think in the couple
hopefulness it though the threat of
death was certainly part of their daily
lives but not it wasn't it wasn't a 10
year in and out experience day in and
day out experience at that point so by
the time I had the opportunity to play
her for Selma and it's now 1960 65 I
thought it's very important to imbue her
with with a weariness and a sense of
burden and the sense of frustration
because this is somebody that was an
academic and intellectual was really
Martin's equal in many ways it was also
an artist but had really been reduced to
I mean it's a worthy thing I'm a mother
myself so I I hesitate using the word
reduce but she had become really mother
of children and wife to Martin and
wasn't necessarily able to express very
much of the rest of who she was so and I
also feel very strongly that by 1965
relative 1955 she'd really bought into
her own image you know there was an
expectation of who she should be and
Avenir had sort of become part of her
persona
and she really played into the facade so
that thankfully was very much evident in
the script to play but on top of that
was this beautiful scene in the center
of the film where you get to see this
wonderful crack in the veneer when
there's an opportunity really to explore
so many of those other dynamic emotional
sides of her and you get a glimpse I
hope into a much more dimensional sense
of who that this woman really was common
you are known in the world as a great
musician and an artist and you make this
beautiful transition of film I just want
to say that I've seen a lot of the
things that you've been in so talk to us
about about working in Selma and also
talk about you know fit the song working
on Selma has been really one of the
greatest experiences I've ever had in my
life there's been life enriching in from
from so many perspectives but I think
the first was really reminding me that
we have a part to play in making the
world better and I felt that I was doing
it in my music and and I knew I would
like do speaking engagements and show up
when people ask me to show up but
getting to do Selma I realized the
diligence that it takes the commitment
that it takes to really be activists and
it put a spark in me like every day I
was coming home from the set I was
thinking about because I was in the
middle of working on music actually I
was thinking how can I have my music be
like soundtracks to this activism that I
want to put in the play and the film
also you know taught me what the
experience actually taught me that you
know no one no one person can can do it
all by themselves you know and you know
getting to see the greatness in Coretta
Scott King and Diane nation' and any Lee
Cooper's and see T Vivian's and for
those great people to be like part of a
team and say we know that this man is
the chosen want to be the voice
it was you know a good humbling lesson
because in many ways that's what we were
as the caste we we had to support our
leader and our leader and and it was
like it just was a good feeling to know
I am I'm a part of this I'm a part of
something special
and I don't have to be in the forefront
like you know this is not about us
shining right you know and I and I and I
appreciated that and and I feel like
what Ava created is a piece of art that
you don't feel the the ego in the film
you don't feel like the intention of let
me show you how great I am the truth
comes out because she cared about she
cares about John Lewis she cares about
people she cares about the the
background actors she cares about the
crew and it just comes doing and in the
film in a way that she cared about the
story and that experience just was like
all those things I was getting fed I was
like man I feel like my life is better
here you know so I'm just grateful to be
a part of this and and basically the
song was a reflection of that song was a
reflection of the experience of getting
to know getting to know the people of
the civil rights movement some of the
names I didn't know and really paying up
honor and tribute to them and saying hey
y'all we got to carry this torch now
like we some we're still alive we have
the opportunity we need to to show I use
that they are the ones that are actually
the future for this and and I just
really we wanted John Legend and I
wanted to bring the song to the present
the way the film is to song it the film
is present you know so the song had to
be that to Ava I want to talk about
shooting on the Pettus Bridge and bridge
that you saw is the actual bridge where
a Bloody Sunday the this all happened
Edmund Pettus actually for those that
don't know is the name of the local
Grand Dragon KKK leader in the area and
that bridge is to this day named after
him which is a darn shame so so anyway
moving on we were on the Edmund Pettus
Bridge which is which is there was a
there was an energetic thing happening
there you know we know that people bled
their that bodies were broken their good
spirits were broken there and then
triumph you know and came back again and
so I think it was something really
beautiful for the actors and David can
speak to it
to perform you know to to have the scene
of a turn around Tuesday where he stands
there and he makes the decision to turn
back around in the actual place where
King did it or at the end of the film
when he gives the final speech at the
actual steps of the the Alabama capital
where where King made that speech and we
actually found the actual podium
no-pressure David give this speech
actually and here's the podium so to
step into those places as actors you
know you know it's just a joy for for us
as a production to be able to you know
give them the actual space to add to
their their work we are actors you know
when cut is cold you know that you are
safe there was no one to call cut on
them when this was going on and and that
in and of itself was something to really
digest also you know when you're making
movies half of your energy is spent on
trying to block out all the apparatus
that goes into making movies cameras
crew lights booms mics all that stuff
but again when you're on that bridge in
that place with those people afforded
that opportunity which really was a
healing opportunity actually because we
now live in a different world we live in
a world where a black woman can direct
this movie this is actually a story I
haven't told before but you know common
and I actually met in 2010 when the
first iteration of this film was trying
to get off the ground and we had read
together me me as king and and common
was reading for the film as well and we
came out and I just had such a bond to
his spirit he's such a beautiful
individual and we walked out together it
was in Studio City just off Ventura
Boulevard and we were walking down the
street together and he's
man I just that was so great can you
just let's just pray together and we we
found a little alley
a little alley off Ventura Boulevard two
grown men praying together and then it
wasn't till another four years till we
got the film off the ground I remember
the first day on set you know we just
looked at each other and we're just like
oh my goodness how divine is this moment
and that kind of thing would just happen
all the time on this Ava and I had
talked about King and not wanting to use
prosthetics not wanting to do anything
that's going to you know distance the
audience from looking into the eyes of
this man and just feeling like you can
do that without any distractions and so
we chose to you know for me to gain
weight rather than you know but have a
false nose and a chin or whatever and
you know in order to get that very
specific thing King had he had this
really quite you know he had a lot going
on down here and and you know I'm just
built differently and even though I've
put on all this way you know I mean I
remember you saying how can we get more
going on you I was like I can do head
weights I don't know what else and Ruth
came up with this idea of a wider color
and then make it to make it smaller
much smaller uncomfortably smaller so
that it just pushed everything up and
gave you that King neck you know and so
you I would put on these shirts look in
the mirror and be like there it is you
know and so that you know before you do
all your work as an actor but for a
costume designer to come along and just
make the suits that bit more more snug
than you otherwise you know it helps
when you look in the mirror and go oh I
feel like I'm that guy and so it's not
just how beautiful they look it's
actually enhancing the performance
that's certainly something she did did
for me as well the timelessness of this
film and just how current it is with
protests happening over the weekend any
comment about that visit did it energize
you they'd say oh my god this film is
coming out at the right time
this film was just supposed to be in the
world right now at this time and I say
that because it is something for
generations to get and see what we can
do as a people to come together it's
like a blueprint for all of us to see
what piece can be in and what love for
Humanity can be and and what it takes to
get there and of course there's new
things that we all have to apply now but
but strategy and hard working and coming
together is gonna work all the time and
to see that happening right now for
people like window window window pierce
was um he was actually in the March and
he said people were bringing up Selma to
him like it's becoming part of the
movement really and it's a beautiful
thing when we can use our art to change
life and in film to change life and so
it's really just the right time for it
and and we need it we need it I feel
like it's a component to it to the whole
movement and the change that we want to
see coming so I mean it's a beautiful
time I mean of course we don't want all
this turmoil going on in the world but
if it is we want to assist in and
changing it and I believe something is
truly a tool for that